farmer's daughter take one
i need to be famous wayne
all the best people are ain't nobody
else out there like you
you know why
why
because you got that x factor
that days of struggling may soon be over
hollywood here we go
this is it our own studio background
i'm looking for a place to stay
oh yes sir
that's one of this home [ __ ]
and my wife pearl was next door so i
would
[Music]
you don't know what we're doing does he
well it's better to beg for forgiveness
and ask for permission
would you like to
come inside
much advice
i want to be in the movie well you can't
the story can't just change midway
through
if daddy catches us
[Music]
there's no telling what he might do
my wife is not well
it happens after darkness
[Music]
you don't want to leave do you people's
eyes are going to pop out of their damn
skulls when i see this
what
are you all right
now
[Music]
all the boys found this inside
what do you think is on it
i see one goddamn [ __ ] up horror
picture
[Music]